comme disait mon banquier le problème
c'est pas de se faire enfiler c'est
juste d'avoir une visibilité sur le
diamètre
des accueille maintenant gaz par Pro
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
ça remonte le moral votre débat à la fin
c'est au cours vers le principe
[Rires]
bon après les polémiques de la semaine
passée la République est passée à autre
chose oui parce que c'est aussi ça la
France la République c'est vraiment une
pouf
quand est-ce là c'est se casse tu vois
ce truc alors tu veux qu'on divertisse
et ben on va t'en donner une
divertissement conasse tiens par exemple
un faux majeur arrivé du Beaujolais
nouveau avec cette question cette année
est-ce qu'il aura le goût de banane
et là sinon hélas donc comme d'habitude
il a ce goût de kiwi macéré dans du
vinaigre
et ouais il y a pas bon Beaujolais
mais cette semaine c'est une semaine
contrairement à ce qui a été discuté
chargé donc positive la magie du
football moi j'adore le football c'est
c'est tellement intelligent c'est
tellement subtil mais comment au 21e
siècle peut-on encore préférer lire un
livre quand on a la chance de ma
terrible on sent un ballon comme un
clébard hystérique aboyant sur le
postier du village c'est d'une beauté
et on a réussi on a battu les Ukrainiens
on est bon on est on est comme ça quoi
nous on arrive à se bouger le cul que
lorsqu'on se fait humilier en fait
autant en tirer quelques leçons le
successeur de déchamps faudra pas le
chercher dans un club de foot mais dans
un club SM
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec
je vois déjà la petite annonce équipe de
baltringue sur friqué blasé cherche
maîtresse dominatrice pour humiliation
planétaire
mais avant cette victoire quelle tapage
alors j'ai regardé la conférence de
presse avant le match et Giroud qui
était prêt à mourir sur la pelouse
encore raté
les mecs qu'il faut arrêter de leur
faire faire des conférences de presse
sont pas équipés pour ça quoi
non faut trouver d'autres moyens pour
qu'ils communiquent leurs émotions je
sais pas le dessin la poterie tu vois un
truc
non mais quand t'entends Giroud en
conférence de presse bon bah tu es
content qu'il fasse pas pilote de ligne
quoi
c'est le mec qui fait commandant de bord
il est capable de cracher l'avion sans
décoller et c'est
alors la question la question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'a dit Deschamps pour
motiver les joueurs moi je sais
j'ai le réseau connais la réponse c'est
ce qu'il a dit vous savez les gars au
Brésil il y en a plein des mecs comme
Zahia
[Applaudissements]
sinon autre chose quelque chose de
majeur oui alors on vient de sauver le
quinquennat contrairement tout ce que on
vient de sauver le quinquennat on a
compris que pour faire plaisir aux
Français il suffit de simplifier les
impôts mais enfin c'est bien sûr
monsieur les Français ils souffrent pas
de pétrole d'impôts au contraire ils ont
raffolent c'est juste qu'ils veulent
comprendre à quelle sauce ils se font
manger c'est tout
comme disait mon banquier le problème
c'est pas de se faire enfiler c'est
juste d'avoir une visibilité sur le
diamètre
[Applaudissements]
parce que là et c'est là où est héros
qui en prend plein la tronche mais il
est il écoute les gens il écoute il
touche une vraie problématique il est au
diapason de la société parce que parce
que ici c'est la préoccupation majeure
des gens enfin il faut être con
t'imagines la famille française typique
le type qui rentre le soir qui rentre de
l'usine il se retrouve à table et que sa
femme et que ces gosses le chômage qui
lui pend au nez il dit à la petite
famille bon écoute Nadine apparemment
ils vont délocaliser le boulot je suis
plus sûr la propriétaire madame roux
elle parle d'augmenter le loyer mais
c'est pas le plus grave il y a plus
inquiétant mais quoi chérie tu as le
cancer tu as flashé sur la bouchère non
c'est pire
c'est pas pour tout de suite la fusion
de la CSG de l'impôt sur le revenu
[Applaudissements]
pour le reste c'est que cette semaine je
dois dire Hollande a été impeccable elle
a trouvé un conflit à sa taille le
Proche-Orient c'est normal pas de
solution simple pour en Orient compliqué
disait de Gaulle c'était une mission
pour Hollande
bonjour Je complique donc ça doit être
simple tu vois du aisance le type c'est
le mec qui chaleure entre les mines et
salamalek entre les barbelés là c'est
c'était lui ou Julien Courbet quoi
problème de voisinage c'est les
meilleurs
non mais quand tu arrives à faire une
coloc avec Vals tobira Montebourg et
désire le Proche-Orient sur une
maternelle
je savais pas mais il est polyglotte il
parle hébreu et arabe c'est le mec c'est
Captain Shalom aleykoum
c'est là où en fait on voit ses limites
plutôt que d'être président et aurait
fait un excellent maire de Deauville ou
de Marseille
peur sur la ville passons à autre chose
alors on a attrapé le méchant ouf alors
moi j'en pouvais plus quoi ça tronche au
JT les chaînes info là c'est pas contre
lui mais bon c'est pas bien enfin on
tient le premier criminel qui est à
l'image de la présidence actuelle quoi
le mec qui n'a aucun cap
[Applaudissements]
le type il hésite chez BFM il canard
d'un stagiaire chez Libé il prend un
otage un mec sur les champs qui relâche
au bout de trois secondes devant
distributeur de la Société générale il
tire trois coups de feu et on le
retrouve dans un parking sous xanax à
Colombes
Mesrine il voit ça il se dit c'est qui
se blaireau quoi
[Applaudissements]
alors on a eu une info alors il
s'appelle Abdelhakim deskar
on comprend mieux pourquoi il a attaqué
l'idée il aurait attaqué minute c'est
lui qui se prenait un coup de fusil à
pompe
[Applaudissements]
mais des choses vont mieux par exemple
en Bretagne en Bretagne on entend moins
les Bretons la contestation c'est
souffle mais ça c'est normal ils ont
détruit tous les portiques
c'est bon quoi c'est pareil qu'il reste
un portique et de radar qui marche en
Bretagne c'est bon c'est cool maintenant
si tu as une conduite un peu sportive
grâce au bonnet rouge Paris c'est à deux
heures de Quimper
[Applaudissements]
parlons monnaie on a emprunté 4,5
milliards pour solder l'ardoise du
Crédit Lyonnais alors pas d'inquiétude
Thomas Fabius se porte caution
[Rires]
international c'est deux lionsceaux sont
nés dans le zoo de Gaza ouais alors bon
il y a un truc qui porte les noms des
deux roquettes tirées vers Israël
non mais attention c'est des roquettes
super importantes c'est les seuls qui
ont passé le mur donc est-ce que les
mecs c'est pas des artilleurs quoi c'est
pas avec eux en face Verdun ça aurait
durer une après-midi quoi tu vois
moi je les trouve d'ailleurs assez dur
les Palestiniens avec la colonisation
israélienne une colonise c'est il faut
être un peu honnête en général quand tu
colonies c'est pour accaparer des
ressources
non mais coloniser la Palestine je veux
dire à moins d'être fasciné par les
Mercedes des années 60 le sable et
l'huile d'olive
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas
happy birthday on commémore le
cinquantenaire de la mort de Kennedy bon
ok mais faut arrêter quel frimeur quand
même rouler en décapotable à 22 novembre
faut pas s'étonner qu'après tu attrapes
un coup de froid carabiné quoi c'est
[Applaudissements]
mais quelle est la vraie bonne nouvelle
et bah dans le cadre d'un plan pour la
lutte contre l'obésité à Moscou on peut
avoir un ticket de métro gratuit contre
30 flexion ouais j'ose pas imaginer ce
qu'il faut faire pour le bus gratuit à
Mykonos alors
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu